[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrige serien hallo und guten abend
ihnen alle norbert könig später mit dem
blick zur frauenfußball wm und zum
tennis ja sehr gerne genannt und das
hält der donnerstag bei uns für sie
bereit
jetzt also doch nach vielen skandalen
muss boris johnson vom parteivorsitz
zurück treten will aber vorerst
premierminister bleiben
frostige gespräche unter palmen
außenministerin werburg will beim g20
treffen auf bali den druck auf russland
erhöhen
und geplatzter traum in wimbledon
tatiana maria kämpft erneut aber
verliert im halbfinale gegen ihre
freundin monster aus tunesien
[Musik]
unter massiven druck steht boris johnson
ja schon seit monaten aber selbst jetzt
wurde es ihm zu viel nach einer
beispiellosen rücktrittswelle von partei
und kabinettsmitgliedern und vielen
skandalen ist der britische premier
jetzt zurückgetreten vorerst nur als
chef der konservativen tories premier
will er trotz erheblichen gegenwinds
noch bis oktober bleiben aus london
yasin herrlein
falls sich irgendjemand darüber
gewundert haben sollte warum boris
johnson sich so lange geweigert hat das
unvermeidliche einzusehen die erklärung
hierfür lieferte der noch premier in
einer ansprache an die nation heute
mittag von number 10 downing street
der grund warum ich so hart darum
gekämpft habe mein amt auf trag
weiterhin persönlich zu erfüllen ist
nicht weil ich es schlicht wollte
sondern weil ich dachte dies sei mein
job und meine pflicht ihnen gegenüber
da war er also wieder der boris johnson
den alle kennen selbst im moment des
niedergangs scheinbar unbeirrt und vom
einräumen eventuelle fehler meilenweit
entfernt stattdessen sein ganz
persönliches bedauern dass es nun vorbei
ist
ich weiß dass es leute geben wird die
jetzt erleichtert sind aber vielleicht
auch einige die enttäuscht sind und ich
möchte sie wissen lassen wie sehr ich es
bedauere den besten job der welt
aufzugeben
dazu gedrängt hatte ihn die flut eine
rücktritten von mitarbeitern seiner
regierung die sich heute früh
fortgesetzt hatte nun versucht johnson
mit den verbliebenen eine
übergangsregierung aufzustellen für die
opposition ist dies zu wenig und zu spät
er hat auch lügen betrug und chaos über
das land gebracht wir stecken fest mit
einer regierung die in diesen zeiten der
wirtschaftlichen krise nicht
funktionsfähig ist und alle die ihn
unterstützt haben sollten sich schämen
zumal johnson als premier ja sogar noch
eine weile weitermachen will solange bis
ein nachfolger oder eine nachfolgerin
für den parteivorsitz der konservativen
gefunden ist so manche in der partei
sind damit aber nicht einverstanden das
politdrama um boris johnson ist noch
nicht endgültig abgeschlossen
gehen wir nach london zu andrea stamm
andreas immenser druck auf johnson wie
groß ist die chance dass er bis herbst
durchhält
es gibt große widerstände keine frage da
sind viele die sich fragen nach all dem
was passiert ist wie kann das denn sein
dass wir diesen mann noch länger
ertragen müssen wenn es auch für einen
begrenzten zeitraum sein dürfte aber
boris johnson so scheint es hat eben mit
den granden der partei der fraktion
absprachen getroffen dient vielleicht
auch das aussteigen etwas versüßt haben
er soll eben geschäftsführend die
regierung weiterführen um nicht neue
vorhaben anzustoßen das ist
ausgeschlossen aber eben die krisen der
jetztzeit im auge zu behalten ukraine
steigende inflation explodierenden
lebenshaltungskosten und währenddessen
wird die tory partei eben sein
nachfolger seine nachfolgerin suchen der
zeitplan solle nächste woche
bekanntgegeben werden aber das dürfte
bis in den herbst dauern aber wenn es
dann so weit ist wird es denn unter
neuer britischer führung eine neue
europapolitik geben
da sind große fragezeichen angebracht
denn der auswahlprozess ist ganz klar es
wird eine riesige bewerberliste geben
dass das das steht nicht das steht
sozusagen nicht in den sternen sondern
das weiß jeder es werden viele viele
sich bewerben und dann wird die fraktion
aus sieben aber am ende gehen die zwei
verbleibenden kandidaten ins endspiel
und da entscheidet die basis der partei
das sind so 100 150000 so genau weiß man
das nie aber die sind natürlich extrem
konservativ und auch extrem
europakritische wer also hofft dass die
eiszeit johnson vorbei ist wenn man hat
mit ihm ja oft nur gesprochen weil man
musste zum beispiel in sachen ukraine
der dürfte sich fragen ob das tauwetter
wirklich kommt denn das ist wirklich
wirklich sehr schwierig weil eben die
basis aussucht und die ist eben europa
kritisch dankeschön nach london andrea
stamm und zum johnson rücktritt auf
raten haben wir ein zdf spezial ins
programm genommen gleich hier im
anschluss an unsere sendung
bevor sie morgen in die sommerpause geht
es heute nochmal ein ziemlich intensiver
tag für die
bundestagsabgeordneten gleich eine ganze
reihe neuer gesetze wurden
beziehungsweise werden noch beschlossen
vor allem zur stärkung erneuerbarer
energien demnach sollen bis 2030 80
prozent des verbrauchten stroms aus
klimafreundlichen quellen wie sonne
wasser oder wind stammen aktuell liegt
der anteil bei knapp unter 50 prozent
außerdem sollen künftig zwei prozent der
flächen für windenergie zur verfügung
stehen mehr erfahren wir jetzt von
patricia wiedemeier
die bundesregierung sieht drückt aufs
tempo beim klimaschutz in salzgitter
legt der kanzler den virtuellen
spatenstich für eine fabrik in der
künftig klimaneutral batterien für e
autos gebaut werden sollen
allen ist inzwischen klar dass diese
zukunft nachhaltig und klima schont sein
muss darum hat sich deutschland
verpflichtet bis 2045 klimaneutral zu
sein zeitgleich feiern in berlin die
grünen dass endlich der schalter
umgelegt wird das heute zwei große
energie gesetzespakete beschlossen
werden im bundestag dann rechnen grüne
und spd mit der vorgängerregierung ab
kein plan kein überblick aber sagen das
was wir jetzt machen ist
schönwetterpolitik sehr geehrten damen
und herren buchstäblich steht
deutschland im regen hätten wir diese
pakete vor zehn jahren durchgezogen wir
würden ganz anders heute davon wir
mussten kämpfen kämpfen gegen salat
deckel gegenwind abstandsregeln sie
standen auf der bremse 16 jahre lang die
ampel regiere von oben durch so die
kritik der union und die
energiegewinnung aus biomasse und
wasserstoff komme zu kurz die co2
intensive kollegen hoch die biomasse
gedeckelt das hat mit grüner politik im
sinne eines ökologischen verstehen ist
es nichts zu tun die fdp fordert mehr
atomenergie anstelle von windkraft es
handelt sich hierbei eben nicht um
romantische windrädchen sondern um
monster anlagen für umweltverbände heute
alles nur ein anfang im herbst müssten
weitere gesetze folgen zum beispiel für
einfachere genehmigungsverfahren
kanzler scholz stellt sich heute bei
maybrit illner den fragen von
bürgerinnen und bürgern den livestream
können sie sie jetzt schon in der zdf-
heute- app und auf unseren social media
kanälen verfolgen oder im fernsehen dann
ab 22 uhr 25
seit anfang juni gibt es das neun euro
ticket und es kommt offenbar gut an
zahlen belegen deutlich mehr menschen
als sonst fahren mit der bahn im
vergleich zum vormonat juni 2009 10 gab
es im schnitt 42 prozent mehr
bahnreisende das ergab eine auswertung
der mobilfunkdaten durch das
statistische bundesamt an samstagen
betrug der anstieg sogar 83 prozent
dafür war es auf den straßen etwas
ruhiger der rückgang liegt allerdings
nur im einstelligen prozentbereich
und noch eine positive entwicklung beim
thema verkehr es gibt so wenig
verkehrstote wie seit 60 jahren nicht
mehr im vergangenen jahr starben
2562 menschen bei unfällen auf den
straßen
das waren 5,8 prozent weniger als im
vorjahr und auch die zahl der verletzten
ging zurück um 1,3 auf 300 23.000
ferda ataman ist heute im bundestag zur
anti diskriminierungs beauftragten
gewählt worden aber noch nie hat es im
vorfeld so viel wirbel um die wahl zu
diesen posten gegeben hintergrund ist
dass die gebürtige stuttgarterin mit
türkischen wurzeln in ihrer früheren
arbeit als journalistin und publizistin
häufig polarisierte über die wahl und
die reaktionen heike slansky
applaus für die frisch gewählte
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte an der
sich bis zuletzt die geister schieben
ferda ataman expertin für migration und
vielfalt streckt nun ihren kritikern die
hand auch diejenigen die mir ihr
vertrauen noch nicht schenken konnten
möchte ich gerne mit meiner arbeit
überzeugen
hatte man die als publizistin gerne
zuspitzte hat mal deutsche als kartoffel
bezeichnet bundesinnenminister seehofer
warf sie vor den heimatbegriff politisch
instrumentalisiert zu haben afg und
union sind sich einig ackermann
polarisiere grenze aus und tauge nicht
als vermittler sie hat beispielsweise
den islamismus kleingeredet unter dem
deckmantel der antidiskriminierung und
sie geht davon aus dass diskriminierung
nur durch weiße deutsche ohne
migrationshintergrund
betrieben werden kann eine kontroverse
personalie ihrer oft provokanten tweets
fast 10.000 an der zahl hat sie gelöscht
auch unter den ampelkoalition ehren gibt
es zweifler innerhalb der fdp es ist ein
unterschied ob man eine meinung hat die
man die polarisiert und die die man auch
tolerieren kann darum geht es gar nicht
oder ob man ein öffentliches amt ausübt
und da halte ich sie nicht für geeignet
um glaubwürdig mit gleichem maßstab
gegen diskriminierung vorzugehen in
einer weise die auch akzeptanz bekommt
in unserer gesellschaft werde ackermann
ist bekannt als engagierte
person
für eine inklusive und demokratische
gesellschaft
theatermann ist nun auf fünf jahre vom
bundestag gewählt
der ukrainische präsident selen ski hat
die von westlichen staaten gelieferte
artillerie gelobt ihre genauigkeit sei
exakt das was gebraucht werde sieben
haubitzen aus deutschland sollen im
östlichen kriegsgebiet im einsatz sein
unterdessen sind in der umkämpften stadt
kammerchors erneut russische raketen
eingeschlagen genaue opferzahlen liegen
nicht vor und die propaganda schlafen um
die schlangen insel die geht weiter care
veröffentlichte diese bilder russlands
militär erklärte der ukrainische posten
sei inzwischen durch luftangriffe
zerstört worden
der krieg in der ukraine ist auch ein
thema bei dem treffen der
aussenministerinnen und minister der
g-20 auf bali das sind die wichtigsten
industrie und schwellenländer es könnte
eisige stimmung in den tropen herrschen
denn der russische außenminister lavrov
ist auch angereist und traf sich heute
mit seinen amtskollegen aus china und
der türkei die allermeisten westlichen
diplomaten werden ihn wohl weniger
freundlich begegnen
außenministerin baerbock sagte nach
ihrer ankunft es werde kein direktes
gespräch mit lawrow aufgeben
auf bali dabei ist andreas künast
andreas russland sitzt mit am tisch was
kann das treffen jetzt bringen
ich weiß nicht ob es so ein g 20 treffen
schon mal gegeben hat hier prallen
wirklich welten aufeinander vor wenigen
minuten ist ein empfang zu ende gegangen
auf dem die indonesischen gastgeber aber
auch china und indien im prinzip ganz
freundschaftlich angestoßen haben mit
russlands außenminister lawrow auf der
anderen seite die westlichen staaten
darunter deutschland die nicht nur auf
die teilnahme an diesem sektglas termin
verzichtet haben sondern die auf alles
verzichten was na business as usual
aussehen könnte auf jedes gemeinsame
foto auf jedes gemeinsame lächeln auf
jeden gemeinsamen handschlag aber sie
wollen dieses g20 format auch nicht
schädigen und deswegen werden sie morgen
bei der arbeitssitzung sabrow spricht
nicht den raum verlassen sondern sie
werden ihm antworten sie werden sagen
herr lavrov beenden sie diesen krieg und
dafür ausgeguckt haben sie sich die
aktuelle vorsitzende der g7 die deutsche
außenministerin annalena baerbock danke
für die information aus bali über das
live andreas künast die regierung in den
niederlanden muss den ausstoß von
stickstoff hauptsächlich verursacht
durch gülle drastisch senken so will man
die klimaziele der eu einhalten dafür
sollen landwirte einen teil ihres
tierbestandes aufgeben das aber wollen
die bauern nicht hinnehmen und und
protestieren seit tagen gegen dieses
vorhaben blockieren mit traktoren
straßen oder versperren die zufahrten
von supermarkt lagerhallen grüner krüger
jetzt für uns mit den einzelheiten
naturschutz und viehwirtschaft das
verträgt sich meint milchbauer ihre
kröten doch seine regierung sieht das
anders
brommer des kabinetts die pläne des
kabinetts greifen tief in die betriebe
ein in die bauernfamilien die jahrelang
auf dem flachen land mit der natur
gelebt haben sie sind verzweifelt ihre
sorge ist enorm
und darum schneit es in diesen
sommernächten stroh vor dem haus der
zuständigen ministerin
meinungsforscher harte maßnahmen sind
notwendig das ist eine tatsache der
stickstoff ausstoß muss sinken in über
100 gebieten wir sie deshalb den ausstoß
von stickoxid um bis zu 70 prozent
senken den fi bestand und mindestens 30
prozent reduzieren denn gülle enthält
stickstoff belastet in seinen
verbindungen luft wasser klima direkt
direkte grund sind gerichtsurteile dass
wir jetzt etwas unternehmen müssen aber
man sieht auch die natur baut immer
weiter ab pflanzen und tierarten
verschwinden
radikale bauern haben ihre argumente
brennende strohballen gefällte bäume
vorschlaghämmer
dienstag dann diese szene waffeln braven
fakir warnschüsse von polizisten der
stickstoff macht das land nervös solche
radikalen aktionen kosten sympathie sagt
auch bauer leuten alle niederländern ist
klar das kleine land stößt an seine
grenzen
es waren bilder die um die welt gingen
vor fast vier jahren stürzte in genua
die vielbefahrene morandi brücke ein
heute hat der prozess gegen die
mutmaßlichen verantwortlichen begonnen
mehr als 50 angeklagte stehen unter
anderem wegen fahrlässiger tötung vor
gericht die morandi autobahnbrücke war
am 14 august 2018 während heftiger
regenfälle auf einer länge von mehr als
200 metern eingestürzt und hatte
dutzende fahrzeuge mit in die tiefe
gerissen
43 menschen kamen ums leben
wir sind beim sport norbert gleich zur
frauen-fußball-wm aber vorher zu einem
tennis märchen das fast wahr geworden
wäre tolle geschichte grundsätzlich aber
schon es war ein traumhaftes turnier für
sie das ist jetzt zu ende gegangen aber
kein grund zum jammern die 34 jährige
tatjana maria hat großartiges geleistet
auf londoner rasen hin zum schluss war
die tunesierin labor am samstag
finalistin gegen die kasachen rybak ina
einfach etwas stärker
eine besondere geste unter freundinnen
die siegerin teilt den publikumsjubel
mit tatjana maria im moment und sie
wollte trotzdem wir zusammen den
genießen deswegen war es auf alle fälle
was besonderes nach verlorenem ersten
satz drehte sie das match ihre
unterschnittene bälle brechen ja bloß
rhythmus ein stop hinterher mit erfolg
satzausgleich 6 zu 3 der dritte und
entscheidende durchgang tatjana maria
verliert ihr service gleich zweimal und
kann diesen rückstand trotz beherzter
gegenwehr nicht mehr einholen
oskar bier erreicht mit 6 2 3 6 und 6 zu
1 zum ersten mal in ihrer karriere im
grenzland finale ein besonderer erfolg
für das poster girl der arabischen und
afrikanischen frauen welt
der titelverteidiger tritt wieder gelb
hat der poker hat auf der sechsten
etappe der längsten der diesjährigen
tour de france die gesamtführung
übernommen
unnachahmlich und unwiderstehlich der
antritt des slowenen 200 meter vor dem
zielstrich im juni in lothringen dacia
hat jetzt vier sekunden vorsprung auf
den us-amerikaner nielsen paulus
es kann losgehen für bundestrainerin
martina voss tecklenburg und die
fußball-nationalmannschaft der frauen
morgen steigt das dfb-team ein in die
europameisterschaft in england mit dem
ersten gruppenspiel gegen dänemark
egal wen man spricht hier im team
quartier vor den toren von london vor
dem duell mit dem europameisterschafts
zweiten von 2017 alle sprühen geradezu
vor vorfreude und optimismus wir haben
sehr sehr gut trainieren werden eine
gute energie alle sind fit wir haben
eine gute fröhlichkeit eine gute
stimmung das alles wird auch nötig sein
nach den enttäuschungen bei den letzten
großen turnieren vor fünf jahren
beispielsweise noch unter steffi jones
das em-aus gegen die dänen
nur drei wochen nach ihrer corona
infektion ist auch kapitänin alexandra
popp eine option für den deutschen em
auftakt am
5 um 21 uhr bei uns im zdf um 20 46
schon sportstudio live mit spanien gegen
finnland dann vielen dank norbert das
kann ich ihnen jetzt schon sagen den
nächsten tagen wird es wieder trockener
mehr wetter gleich mit osten telli um 21
55 im heute-journal ordnet marietta
slomka unter anderem noch mal die never
ending story um boris johnson ein und
hier geht es weiter jetzt mit dem zdf
spezial schönen abend schön dank und bis
morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ja noch bekommen
war eher kühle luft aber auf der
ostseite dieses sehr umfangreichen hochs
aber die wird allmählich abgeschnürt
denn das hoch dehnt sich aus und
gleichzeitig bildet sich hier über
spanien eine hitze glocke die wird
später frankreich erreichen und ob sie
dann nach deutschland kommt ist noch
nicht ganz klar wenn das passiert wird
ziemlich heiß nächste woche schauen wir
in die nacht und da gibt es schauer und
gewitter vor allem nach osten hin das
zieht relativ rasch ab im süden bleibt
es länger ansonsten lockert es teilweise
auf und die temperaturen sinken auf 9
grad nach westen hin und 15 grad an der
ostsee und dort gibt es morgen im
tagesverlauf schauer und auch richtung
erzgebirge und ganz im süden es lässt
allmählich nach viel sonnenschein gibt
es dann richtung oberrhein die
temperaturen erreichen höchstwerte von
26 grad ganz im westen und teilweise 18
19 bis 20 grad im norden oder 18 grad an
den alpen die nächsten tage am samstag
gibt es im nordosten vor allem noch
schauer und dann wird das auch
nachlassen bis 27 grad und danach
vereinzelt schauer damit ein schöner
abend